um so he called me and he's like hey  tomorrow I want you to have them deflate  the balls a little bit because I'm  really going to hit these kids tomorrow  and I I was like haha that's funny Adam  he's like no no no I'm really I'm  serious and he's like this is a comedy  rule Tamara hurting kids in comedy is  funny  so I hit some kid pretty hard and he  gets upset and he starts crying and then  the parents all come up to me they're  like hey what's the deal they're the kid  you nailed that kid I was like oh no no  that's the scene I'm supposed to sound  like a big guy I went back to school I'm  supposed to plug all these kids it's  part of the joke and they were like oh  no no no I said well then they read the  script they go They're six they don't  read yet I said all right I won't do it  or something and I think I told the guys  to roll anyways and I nailed a bunch of  kids and uh those kids uh grew up and  guess who they are today uh I don't know  [Applause]